welcome to the heavy spoiler show i'm
your host paul
and with just three episodes left of
lovecraft country
we're finally starting to see how the
show is shaping up throughout this video
we're going to be breaking down the
latest episode
and also going over our theories the
easter eggs
and things you missed there will be
heavy spoilers here so if you haven't
had a chance to check out the episode
yet then i highly recommend that you
check out now
i'm actually i'm actually on holiday
right now making this video from a hotel
room
so i'd massively appreciate it if you
drop a thumbs up on the video
thank you as always for clicking this
now let's get into the breakdown
okay so the title of the episode is
[ __ ] bobo
now the word is the combination of two
and the first part comes from the word
[ __ ]
which is a derogatory term for a black
person the word originates from bantu
and it means servant typically it was
used as a way to describe
slaves and sadly it's been dropped a lot
in society to oppress people
i was a bit unsure on whether to discuss
the full meaning behind it
but i feel that it's important to not
brush over these kinds of things
and we should discuss how the words have
been used in the past even if i don't
condone its application ever
the second part of the word bobo means a
child born on a tuesday in ghanian
however it has been used generally to
mean children
you might remember that it was used last
week as the nickname of emmett till
whose funeral we open on at robert's
temple
till is very much laced throughout the
episode and his tie
is even used on the title card in the
introduction in real life till was
brutally murdered by white racists
and they beat him until he looked
unrecognizable emmett's mother insisted
on an open casket to expose what had
happened to his son
and he has become a symbol of the civil
rights movement
sadly an all-white jury found his
killers not guilty
even though they admitted to it later
under the double deputy rules they were
not prosecuted
until has become an iconic figure of
inequality
we see members of both the christian
church and nation of islam speaking up
showing how this horrific crime affected
people of all faith
cutting through the scenes of policemen
and the force very much becomes the
overarching villains of the peace
in the background we can hear cruel
summer by bananarama
and we see as a woman vomits due to the
sight of emmett's body
to make matters worse it's one of the
hottest days of the air and the smell of
emmett's corpse
wafts down the crowd which is where we
join ruby and d
due to letty's pregnancy she's finding
it difficult to stand
and we also see how the revelation about
montrose last week
still has the pair on less than speaking
terms predominantly throughout this
episode we follow dee
hippolyta and george's child as she
comes face to face with just how ugly
the world is
even though hippolyta stated last week
that she wished to return to d to be her
mother
the showrunners confirmed that after the
episode h did not return from her
journey
and thus dee is left on her own without
either of her parents
i do think that age will actually return
at some point
but it may not be for for quite a while
yet now when d
disappears tick doesn't seem to be
bothered and i have a feeling that he
saw something through the portal last
week that may have given him some
inkling to future events
we'll discuss this later in the video
this episode itself is actually a
reframing of a chapter from the book
in which we follow a character named
horus who is chased by something known
as the devil doll
horus is actually the son of georgian
hippolyta in the source material
and similar to this episode captain
lancaster places a curse on him
horus is actually name dropped in this
entry along with some of the characters
such as caleb and george surviving the
events of the lodge
now the [ __ ] bobos are incredibly
scary and i feel like we might actually
get introduced to them early on
with us witnessing two girls eating ice
cream and laughing
i didn't actually learn this until you
guys told me in the ruby episode
but under the jim crow laws at the time
black people weren't allowed to have
vanilla ice cream
seeing the pair having it does hint that
something else might be going on
and the sight of them causes dee to lose
it a bit and she ends up throwing rocks
at them
captain lancaster then arrives and
interrogates her down a back alley
asking questions about hippolyta the
comic cover that we ended on last week
must have been found along with the
bodies of his men and he wants to know
what's going on
he places a curse on d and we also get a
quick flash of a cream of wheat
advertisement
throughout the series we've seen how
black people are portrayed in
advertising
to be either ancient type characters or
what's referred to as uncle toms
just recently uncle ben's actually
removed this kind of advertising from
their products
as it reinforces certain stereotypes
many of which
align with the demons in this episode
also yeah
don't don't spit on a kid's head what
the what the hell is wrong with you
now we cut to letty on her search for
diana and she comes face to face with
giar who's traveled over from korea for
radicus
speaking of atticus he meets with
christina who's in a crypt
i was kind of hoping we're getting not
to kayla breath right here but we do get
one with the boogazabo so
all's well that ends well now atticus
wants to learn magic
and after his journey last week it's
clear he's found something that's
changed his perspective on things
in exchange for the key that was found
inside the ori christina explains how to
protect oneself when casting spells
she says spells take energy intention
and a body
the latter of which was of course at a
kiss when samuel tried to sacrifice
him just as she's leaving christina is
stopped dead in her path by the mention
of the equinox
which you may remember was also name
dropped in the second episode
as being needed for the immortality
ceremony christina says that she's going
to be the first to achieve this
and as we know this failed in the case
of both titus and samuel
d goes to montrose looking for answers
and he mentions that his best friend was
taken 2 when he was younger
which is likely a nod to the tulsa
massacre d tries to wash off the curse
but after failing to do so put on a
chicago american giants cap
these were actually a fully african
american baseball team
that were based in chicago which is
where this episode takes place
there's also the book uncle tom's cabin
which was an anti-slavery novel that is
said to have helped lay the groundwork
for the civil war
in the 19th century it was the second
best-selling book next to the bible
and it fueled the abolitionist cause in
the 1850s
the character on the cover actually
comes to life in this entry and it's
very important to pay attention to it
here
ruby arrives at williams and after a
confrontation with a racist that william
has to defuse
the two get it on we hear i put a spell
on you by alice smith
which is of course a nod to the magic
between the pair ruby takes the potion
to transform herself
and we get the feeling that both she and
william are in love but they have to
live a lie
and hide away their true selves in order
to be together
this is of course echoed in montrose and
we get the feeling that the truth
shouldn't be hidden away
as dell's skin sheds during their
intercourse ruby later goes to christina
furious over emmett's death and in
general the way that white society
treats black people
christina doesn't seem to care and we
very much get the idea
that ruby doesn't either deep down
because she's working purely on her base
desires and addictions
in the book she becomes very much
attached to the potion
and craves it almost like a narcotic
this is likely because she's just fed up
and sees it as a means of escape rather
than a solution
across town tick arrives home to find
letty and gr's shoes outside of his
house
in korea one is expected to remove their
shoes upon
entering someone's home as koreans tend
to eat and sleep on the floor
and thus not removing them is seen as
very disrespectful
he finds jia and letty sitting in a very
uncomfortable silence
and he should have just turned around
and walked out right there
now gr discusses the kumeo curse that
was placed on her
and we learned that there was also 100
men's lives taken in order to lift it
the last time we left her she was on 99
i do get the feeling that the final one
was actually her mother she doesn't
really have any answers
and i don't know why she did this big
trip to just to have this tiny
conversation
but i good to see her back and i'm sure
she'll pop up again before the finale
tick and letty have a big fight and he
says he held back the information from
her because he wanted to protect people
we saw how montrose attempted to do the
same thing and that he
like his son has even lied and killed to
cover things up
leti says that in doing this everyone
has died including her at one point
and we realize how dangerous it is to
keep secrets
see whenever whenever your ex comes into
things it always gets complicated
now ticks says he's gonna cast a spell
that will protect them
and the pair depart on bad terms dee
makes her way across
town avoiding the police but something
much worse comes with the cover of the
book coming to life in the form of two
girl demons
this is actually known as the watermelon
stereotype
and we hear this song stop that knocking
by af winner more play in the background
as they stalk her on the train tracks
these chica bobos follow her throughout
the entry
and we even see at one point another
reference to a horror classic
when we can see three girls playing jump
rope in the street
this is a nod to nightmare on elm street
and the song they sing
sounds sounds very much like one two
freddy's coming for you that's why i
don't do voices in the breakdown
now d bumps into letty and tries to tell
her about the curse
but she's unable due to it holding
restrictions over her voice
i think this might actually be a
metaphor for how the police can often
silence black people into speaking out
against them
but let me know your thoughts on if you
interpreted it another way
defines woody aka her mother's car which
you can guess that tick used to return
home with last week
maybe maybe h is just walking home right
now but let me know your theories on
exactly where she is now montrose and
take have a father and son chat
in which the truth about his sexuality
comes out into the open
you also see a sign that says closed for
emmett further showcasing how the young
child's death rocks society
montrose tells a story about how he knew
a man that was gay
and police arrested him and sent him to
an asylum where half of his brain was
cut out
at the time homosexuality was viewed as
a psychological condition
known as a disordered mind and many gay
people were persecuted and operated on
by institutions
montrose didn't want this for himself
and thus he hid it away from society
both he and dora wanted a family and he
still views this as a form of love
ticks says he went through the portal to
the future and reveals that his son
george
wrote the lovecraft country book we saw
last time this was
not part of the novel at all and it's
interesting to see this fourth wall
breaking moment
tick named him after george and it's
becoming more and more apparent that
he was actually his real father across
town leddy is praying in a church
to grant protection for tick letty
didn't actually believe in god
but after dying she's gained some more
appreciation for religion
and magic in general christina enters
and we learn that she was contacted by
letty
who wished to give her a photograph of
the pages in exchange for protection
over atticus
christina refuses and instead gives it
to letty
branding her with the same mark that we
saw on william's chest
this is the mark of kane which was a
spell passed on through the bright
whites
that can actually be used to heal
someone it's now night
and dee is still on the run she arrives
at the police station to follow captain
lancaster
and i still can't get over just how
creepy those [ __ ] bobos are
i love when i show a film create a new
kind of monster
and just the way they move and dance
about in the darkness is
so unnerving that it makes this one of
the scariest episodes
so far d follows lancaster and tick
tells montrose about the future
in which he witnessed riot there's talk
of a woman with a robotic arm
and this might actually be dee who we
see later has something strange happened
to hers
they read the bleb of the book aka their
family story
and mention many of the key changes in
the show they also discuss how christina
sacrifices tick
in order to become immortal during the
equinox montrose swears to sacrifice
himself if it comes down to it
i very much get the feeling that he
might actually be the one that dies
though the book doesn't really have any
of the major players going out
again this seems to be its own thing
right now and who knows what's going to
happen
cut to lancaster reading a story about
letty and they mention pioneering which
often refers to someone entering an
unfounded land
and lancaster clearly isn't happy about
her
he wants the ori from the house but as
we know it's already been opened
dee storms in and starts asking
questions and lancaster promises to
remove the curse
if she brings the device to him but she
refuses to
and instead calls him a pig he says
she's already dead
and we see as the [ __ ] bobos start to
close in
in the background we can hear naomi
wadler's speech in which he discusses
the death of black girls that don't ever
make the news
she states that black girls are often
seen as statistics and numbers
when we should value their lives black
girls are actually murdered at a
disproportionate rate
and it's a very powerful speech the
episode ramps up from this point onwards
with the monsters closing in but dee
lets out a massive scream
as she writes by them cut to montrose
and ticks setting up a production circle
and we learn the former is dyslexic
which atticus didn't know about
it kind of hints at how many secrets
he's keeping from his son
and that he already may know that george
is his true father they start to enact a
spell in the language of adam
but this seemingly fails we occur to
christina
and discover that she's paid two men to
enact amitel's murder on her
so that she can see firsthand what it
was like it's agonizing to watch
and it reminds us of just how brutally
actual crime was
now unlike tell christina doesn't die
due to the mark of kane
but she experiences it firsthand and
comes out crying
before this starts to turn into a weird
laugh
now i don't know exactly what's going on
here but the truth about her does come
out to letty
when we join ruby confessing their
relationship she says she knows the
truth about what's going on
and is also disappointed because letty's
child will of course be tied to
this horrendous horrendous legacy ruby
has a really powerful speech
in which she says she wants to create
her own space to live in so that she
doesn't have to suffer the prejudices of
others
just as she's about to discuss how
christina will help her to do this
lancaster and his forces arrive they
have a fake warrant on the basis that
the nation of islam is at the location
and they state that they believe they're
trying to plan retribution for emmett
till
i think this might be similar to the
algiers motel incident which the film
detroit was based on
police arrived at the motel accusing
people of writing
and unlawfully murdered several black
people the officers were found not
guilty
and it again shows just how unjust
society is
luckily because of the spell put on the
property in episode 3
they're unable to enter and you might
remember that christina was held back
from doing this too
this stops people with magic from
entering but they begin to shoot at the
home
and everyone has to take cover at this
point d
finds a way to have a voice and this
involves writing down what is happening
to her on a piece of paper
the [ __ ] bobo swarm her but she
manages to beat them with a pipe
before montrose arrives they do
something weird to her arm
and as we mentioned earlier this may tie
into atticus's journey to the future
tick arrives to find the house being
shot at and the police turned that fire
to him
even though he was surrendering however
this spell clearly worked
and a shoggoth busts out the ground to
protect him again
i know these aren't like shoguts in
lovecraft's work but the show has
changed their appearance much to fit its
new narrative now as we know
their favorite food is policemen and the
beast tears through the crowd
whilst tick runs to leti it's an
incredible one-shot piece
and also lets us know how christina was
able to control them in the first couple
of episodes
lancaster is ripped apart but if you
know the source material then you know
that he's going to be back
and worse than ever before that ends the
episode
and we cut to the promo for next week
but if you don't want anything ruined
then i recommend you turn off now
there's not much
here that really appears in the book but
again you might just want to go into the
episode without any
further information so yeah get the
heart over here
now it looks you can tell this is a 6am
in the morning i'm doing this now
it looks like they're here to find out
about the curse on d
and they go to christina for help they
ask if she will remove dee's arm as it's
slowly turning her into a [ __ ] bobo
and it's likely that the two girls we've
seen were normal people at one time
we see a city burning up and it might
even be possible that this is tulsa
though we don't know for definite yet
the time machine is powered up once more
and it could be there they're traveling
back to the past
yeah like i said it you know it differs
so much from the source material that
it's difficult to tell
but that closes up the episode as well
as our breakdown
now obviously i'd love to hear your
thoughts on the entry so make sure you
comment below and let me know
if you missed any of our other
breakdowns so far then make sure you
check them out after this
as you you definitely gonna have a great
time i think
hopefully now don't forget we're also
giving away three copies of the marvel
phase one box set
and all you have to do to view on the
chance of winning is like the video make
sure you subscribe to the channel
and drop a comment below the win is
going to be chosen at random on the 30th
of october so make sure you get involved
if you want to support the channel and
get to see content early then please
consider clicking the join button below
you can also come chat to us on the
discord server linked in the description
or at heavyspoilers on twitter
thanks for making it until the end of
the video you've been the best i've been
paul i'll see you next time
take care peace i'm off
i'm off to go get drunk now
you